A lot of times we stay because of finances, appearances, kids.
We lie to ourselves to pretend like everything's okay.
When I realized I had to get a divorce,
I had a neighbor that the two of us were having kids at about, like.
We had some kids that kind of lined up in age.
We had pregnancies similar.
We would share. It was like the cutest shit that you would want.
And our husbands were kind of similar.
And I didn't really like her husband,
but I had every excuse in the world for my husband.
I was different. Our relationship was different.
Our. She didn't understand our shit.
But I had, like,
such a fucking judgmental eye for her husband.
And there was a little time that we weren't able to go for walks,
like it was winter or whatever.
And then she said to me, hey,
you know, can we start doing those morning walks again?
Cause I really need a friend.
I need to talk to somebody.
And I was like, yeah,
for sure. And all we could do was, like,
walk two blocks and come back.
We both had to get back to our kids.
And she would tell me these stories
of arguments that she was having with her husband.
And I would be like, wow.
And I would be giving her all this advice, like, girl,
you deserve better. That's not okay.
But when she would tell me the stories,
they were really Like
ringing a bell with shit that was going on in my marriage.
And eventually I had to face myself and be like, wow,
I'm gonna give somebody else this advice.
Like, I can see how wrong it is in somebody else's marriage,
but I'm making every fucking excuse in the book for my marriage.
And thank god I had a friend coming to me,
and I was able to have that internal insight
to realize I'm lying to my goddamn self.
I'm the reason I'm being treated this way,
because I'm fucking staying.
I can leave and I can figure some shit out.
There's no reason I have to stay.
And that's when I fucking woke up and left.
I realized, because you could tell yourself whatever little fancy story,
but at the end of the day,
I thought, what if he died?
What if you were dead and literally not here?
What would I do then? And from that point on,
I started making moves, and I changed my own life.
No one's gonna come and save you.
All those little princess stories.
I think that's the worst fucking thing we can tell our daughters.
Or let our little girls. The lies we let our little girls believe,
is that somebody's gonna come and save you.
This is your fucking life.
You came in this world alone,
and you're gonna fucking die alone.
And it's okay to have relationships and connections while we're here,
but to depend on Another person for every ounce of your everything.
Every ounce of your fucking everything.
Not just your finances, but your fucking worth.
Your out, every bit of. You know,
it's. A lot of women just don't wanna own up to that and realize that.
So if you're happy, you're happy.
But some. Some women know